-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for watching at home.
I am so excited about this.
Steve Martin and Martin Short
are my guests tonight!
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Backstage, I was like,
"You guys are my comedy heroes."
And they were like, "Oh, my God.
We're such big fans of us, too."
Well, I'm in
a good mood right now
because we're right in
the middle of
the holiday season right now,
and I love the holiday season.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love it.
By the way, here's a little tip
for anyone buying presents.
Whatever you buy,
just say you got it on Etsy
so everyone thinks a lot of
thought went into it.
That's what I do.
Of course, gift cards
are always a popular option.
And I like
the Amazon gift cards,
because they basically say,
"The only thing
I 100% know about you
is that you want a gift."
Meanwhile, I saw that tomorrow
is National Christmas Card Day.
And I've already seen some
pretty interesting cards
this year.
I'll show you some of the
ones I've got.
For instance, look at this.
This is a card from Aaron Judge.
On the front, it says...
Open it up, and it says...
You go, "Wait. Come on."
Here's another one I got.
-They're very specific, yeah.
-Here's a card from
"Good Morning America."
It says...
You open it up, it says...
♪♪
-Wow!
-I don't know what it means.
-Morning.
-Here's a card from Joe Biden.
It says...
You open it up, it says...
Wow.
Here's a nice card
I got from Elon Musk.
It says...
Open it up, it says...
-Wow!
-That's nice.
Here's a card from
Herschel Walker. It says...
Open it up, it says...
And you go, "Well, he's trying.
He's trying."
-Yeah, he's trying.
He falls down, he gets back up.
-Yeah. And, finally, here's a
card from Vice President Harris.
It says...
Open it up, it says...
Everyone's in the spirit.
Very nice.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's get to some news.
Everybody's talking about this.
Today, 10 months after
she was detained,
Brittney Griner
was freed from Russian custody
in a prisoner exchange...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
...between The White House
and the Kremlin.
You could tell Biden
was fired up
when he began his speech with,
"It's Brittney [bleep]
And you go, "Hey."
Putin is no stranger
to prisoner swaps.
In fact, "Prisoner Swap"
is the most popular
reality show in Russia.
Yeah, there was a prisoner swap.
In exchange for Griner,
Moscow received
the notorious Russian
arms dealer
who was known as
"The Merchant of Death."
-Ooh!
-Can we see what he looks like?
-When asked for a statement,
he said,
"If your wife has ever said,
'Come move these
rocket launchers
so I can take a bath,'
you might be
an international arms dealer."
Hey, I read that the C.E.O.
of Build-A-Bear Workshop
said 40% of their shoppers are
now teenagers and adults.
It's little surprising,
but it does explain
the new ad campaign.
Check this out.
-At Build-A-Bear Workshop,
we're not just for kids.
We're for kids of all ages,
so the next time
you're at the mall,
stop on by and build a bear.
Build a bestie.
Build a boss.
Build a boyfriend.
Build a better life,
the one you used to dream about
back when everything
still felt exciting and vital,
because age is nothing
but a number,
a big, terrible number,
a grandfather clock
about to strike,
the sound of whose
bong, bong, bong
will never be heard by
the lifeless bear
you clutch to as a totem of
what was once possible
but no longer is.
Build-A-Bear Workshop --
we're going
through something right now.
-Wow!
-That explains it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
-Well, guys,
"Avatar: The Way of Water"
finally comes out next week.
A lot of people are
excited for it.
It's getting great reviews.
But since it's been
almost exactly 13 years
since "Avatar" came out,
we thought it'd be helpful
to recap what happened
in the first movie.
So here now with a rap recap
is Tariq from The Roots.
Take it away, Tariq.
-One, two, three.
-♪ I said, I don't remember ♪
[ Music stops ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-I heard about a man in Florida
who was arrested for
allegedly stealing over
$1,300 worth of
toothbrushes from Walgreens.
Yep, the man was convicted after
four out of five jurors
found him guilty.
Guys, we have
exactly seven shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time for
that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It is time for "12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters."
Here we go.
-♪ "12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters ♪
♪ Seven days left ♪
-That's right.
Every show between
now and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
a magnificent Christmas sweater
from the
Countdown to Christmas Cabinet.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Since there are
seven shows left,
let's open door number 7.
[ Drumroll ]
Ooh! Here, right?
Go for it.
Whenever you're ready.
-Ready.
-Yeah, go.
Oh, wow!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Nice. Thank you very much.
Look at this.
Disco Santa.
Now let's see who's going home
with tonight's sweater.
Everyone look at
your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get
a drumroll, please?
[ Drumroll ]
Who wants a sweater?
This is a goody, this one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here we go!
-Here we go.
-114!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, come on.
Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hi!
Nice to meet you. How are you?
Stand right there.
-Right over here.
-What is your name
and where are you from?
-I'm Jaslene and I'm from
Norwalk, Connecticut.
-Hey! Jaslene, welcome!
Norwalk, it gets very cold
this time of year.
And you have
a beautiful sweater.
-Thank you.
-You almost can't top that.
But then you have this.
Do you have anything like
this in your wardrobe?
-No, it's unique.
-Yes, thank you.
That's a nice way of putting it.
Would you like to try it on
for everyone?
-I would.
-Oh, this is exciting.
There you go. Roots?
There you go, bud.
-Oh, we've got to do
the hands first.
-Oh, yeah,
your hands go through.
Oh, yeah. Oh, no, no, no.
I can already tell.
This is going to be gorgeous.
-I love it.
-Are you -- Come on.
Look at us. You look great.
Come on. How cute.
Yeah, give it up
for our winner right there.
Congratulations.
-Thank you!
-Guys, stick around.
We'll be right back with
Steve Martin and Martin Short.
Come on back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪